[Música]
hola soy sofía calderón y soy de cartago
esto en el colegio san luis gonzaga
donde por bizarro que parezca cerca de
los años 90 todavía algunos profesores
solían
[Música]
solían solían hacernos
aprender palabras de memoria totalmente
de memoria y esta palabra la aprendí
pensando que no me iba a servir pero la
voy a usar hoy y es crisis crisis se
define como una coyuntura de cambio de
cambio abrupto de cambio extremo de
cualquier realidad que usualmente fue
ordenada pero que hoy está sujeta por
supuesto a la evolución y por ende es
totalmente inestable ahora bien decimos
que por qué es importante anticiparnos o
responder al cambio bueno principalmente
porque al ser inesperada suele ser
totalmente paralizante y eso es un lujo
kieny como personas y como
organizaciones podemos darnos hoy en día
ante los black swan y por favor quiero
que se entienda como un black swan un
evento desafortunado que generalmente
tiene un impacto socioeconómico
importante y que se simboliza por
supuesto con un cisne negro decimos que
ante los black swan necesitamos tener
una respuesta o procurar una respuesta
resiliente porque es que se populariza
tanto el término de presidencia en
épocas de crisis bueno sobre todo porque
lejos de ser un conocimiento o un
componente individual más bien es un
proceso de respuesta comunitaria
cultural que busca desde la protección
hasta resurgir de entre las cenizas de
forma más fuerte y generalmente decimos
que la respuesta de siguiente tiene tres
estadios en el tiempo el primero de
ellos tiene que ver con reaccionar no me
voy a tener mucho ahí pero básicamente
es lo que hemos estado haciendo durante
las últimas semanas y los otros dos
tienen que ver más bien con recuperarse
y con resurgir
y porque me enfoco aquí porque hay una
clara realidad lo que dejamos en la
calle hace unas semanas el panorama va a
ser totalmente diferente al panorama oa
la realidad que nos encontremos cuando
salgamos de esta crisis y vamos a tener
que adaptarnos a la nueva normal y para
adaptarnos lo más importante que quiero
que entiendan de esta filmina es que ese
ave blanco simboliza la respuesta que
tenemos que tener debe de ser ágil
valiente y sobre todo empática
ok con tanta información que nos
bombardean todos los días en medios en
redes sociales en el whatsapp en
nuestros colegas nuestro canal
específico de la oficina tenemos mucha
información y solemos perderlos por eso
decimos que necesitamos pragmatismo y
agilidad pragmatismo tiene que ver con
responder rápidamente y para responder
rápidamente vamos a necesitar altas
dosis de conocimiento y aprendizaje y es
por eso que hoy quiero conversar les
alrededor de los esquemas de pensamiento
que son los esquemas de pensamiento
bueno los esquemas de pensamiento
básicamente tienen que ver con un
conjunto de mejores prácticas o de
atributos que en materia de liderazgo
estudiamos de otros líderes que han sido
exitosos en coyunturas como estas de
vulnerabilidad y volatibilidad y hoy en
día decimos que un esquema de
pensamiento es un atajo un atajo para
como venga y llegar de un punto a a un
punto b sin tantos valles ni cimas sino
de forma más rápida
hoy en día dentro de las organizaciones
solemos decir que los líderes más
exitosos no son aquellos que lucen como
superhéroes eso es un concepto del
pasado los líderes de hoy más bien
muestran muchísima vulnerabilidad y
sobre todo son altamente empáticos
de hecho en esta pandemia particular
hemos acuñado exitosamente el concepto
de el sí y hoy en tiempos de crisis que
no es más el gerente general de la
empresa sino que es el chief en patty
officer o el gerente general de la
empatía
muy bien hoy en esta primera en este
primer esquema de pensamiento que les
traigo les voy a hablar de zona de
combate pero no es esa zona de combate
que tenemos en este momento en nuestras
casas con aquella sala hecha una locura
llena de juguetes haciendo homeschooling
y tratando a la vez de trabajar o de
teletrabajar no no es esa
esta historia realmente es tétrica esta
historia tiene que ver con básicamente
los ex prisioneros de la guerra nada más
y nada menos que de la guerra de vietnam
y este es un estudio que se hizo que
hicieron dos psicólogos de hecho en el
año 2008 con 30 ex prisioneros de la
guerra de vietnam que estuvieron
confinados en la cárcel de hoy y por qué
fue que los tomaron a ellos a esos 30
bueno básicamente porque esa muestra de
30 ex prisioneros fueron los que
desarrollaron menos estrés postraumático
después de cinco años de estar
confinados
y además porque fueron los que menos
estuvieron propensos a la depresión
estos psicólogos básicamente encontraron
rasgos importantes que les permitieron
adaptarse a condiciones tan complicadas
la primera de ellas y como lo pueden ver
ahí tiene que ver con el sentido del
humor algo que ha normado
definitivamente en esta crisis en esta
pandemia bueno ellos tenían tan buen
sentido del humor que lejos de llamar a
la cárcel la cárcel dejó a como
realmente se llamaba la llamaron el
hanoi hilton hotels en forma burlista
por las condiciones tan paupérrimas en
las cuales se encontraron
además del humor
estos ex prisioneros lograron
desarrollar grandes grandes cantidades
de vulnerabilidad que significa la
vulnerabilidad en tiempos de crisis
bueno básicamente es mostrarme tal cual
soy pero me ayudó mi ayuda o les ayudo a
ellos a enfatizar y a conectar muchísimo
más con su gente a mostrarse tal cual
eran lo cual obviamente influyó en ser
mucho más empáticos pero no en la
empatía que conocemos no es esa empatía
no es la empatía del concepto trillado
de ponernos en los zapatos del otro esa
no es la empatía que necesitamos en
época de crisis necesitamos de la
empatía inflexible y que es la empatía
inflexible bueno la empatía inflexible
básicamente tiene que ver con darle a la
otra persona lo que necesita en ese
momento de crisis y no necesariamente lo
que quiere voy a parafrasear
es decirle a esa persona que está en una
condición complicada lo que realmente
necesita escuchar y no lo que quiere
escuchar
dejo este concepto de la empatía
inflexible para que a un minuto para
decirles que también u otro rasgo que
fue realmente fundamental y es el de
aceptar la realidad tal cual era lo cual
nos trae a esta paradoja que es la
paradoja de james stockdale que
básicamente acepta la realidad sus
colegas desde sus 30 que estaban ahí
solían hacer apuestas de cuando iban a
salir de la crisis y algunos decían que
iban a salir en navidad algunos otros
decían que iban a salir para su
cumpleaños otros para pascuas
jim stockdale se dejó decir saldremos
cuando debamos de salir y además acepto
con gran interés a su realidad pero no
sólo eso sino que también se ocupó tan
así se ocupó que generó un código donde
golpeaba las puertas a ser un código de
comunicación para golpear las puertas de
sus colegas y generó este código que les
permitió conversar durante tantos años y
que al final del estudio se constata que
es lo que permitió de alguna manera
tanta injusticia y sobre todo generar
mejor sanidad dentro de este grupo de 35
ahora bien ya sabemos lo que significa
la empatía inflexible cuando vemos esta
foto donde particularmente pensamos en
nuestra población más vulnerable en
nuestros adultos mayores
y vemos esa foto y pensamos en que no
los podemos abrazar qué concepto más
importante el de la empatía inflexible
porque en este momento nuestros abuelos
quieren o anhelan un abrazo y nosotros
también pero eso no es lo que necesitan
en momentos de crisis necesitan un amor
diferente un amor que cuide el amor con
rigor
por supuesto que al hablar de liderazgo
tenía que hablar de una mujer y no de
cualquier mujer sino en un tremendo
personaje como lo es golda meier golda
meier es una luchadora infatigable pero
que además estuvo marcada por una
infancia sumamente complicada golda era
la séptima de ocho hermanos y a sus 8
años ya había enterrado a cinco de ellos
producto de una pobreza extrema y sobre
todo de la repercusión antisemita
golda genera siempre este tipo de
reacciones adversas porque era muy su es
en su en su forma de ser y sobre todo en
su vocabulario y la forma de expresarse
y de hecho se dejó decir no sé si las
mujeres son mejores que los hombres pero
de seguro que no son peores
cuántas el perfecto ejemplo de un
marcaje trágico en toda su historia en
toda su carrera
y no en vano es llamada la dama de
hierro de israel hay tres pasajes de la
vida de golda que son necesarios de
enfatizar hoy en día el primero de ellos
tiene que ver con que gorda fue muy
determinada de hecho golda salió de un
kibutz que era un campo agrícola
solidario para básicamente asumir el
ministerio de trabajo algo que fue muy
criticado por los hombres en su momento
claro era en 1950 la segunda tiene que
ver con coraje y con vulnerabilidad
golda es una de las 25 firmantes
del acto de independencia de israel y
cuentan que lloró profundamente cuando
firmo y el tercero tiene que ver con la
energía de hecho gol da en su tercer año
de gestión como ministra general de
israel tiene que afrontar de forma muy
pragmática
el atentado terrorista de los juegos
olímpicos de múnich donde su respuesta
fue tajante y sobre todo determinante
ante esta fuerza arrolladora de golda y
ante esta disciplina tan marcada es
ilógico pensar como nosotros no podemos
básicamente acatar de alguna manera las
órdenes del ministerio de salud y como
el ministro de salud daniel salas el fin
de semana pasado nos tuvo que dar un
jalón de orejas porque andamos en la
calle de indisciplinados como es posible
que no podamos básicamente acatar una
orden que tiene que ver con
responsabilidad colectiva
mi tercera historia por supuesto no
puede cerrar con nada más y nada menos
que comienzo mandela nelson mandela
escribe 250 cartas desde la cárcel de
hecho sus captores dicen que es en las
cartas y en ese va y viene de
comunicación que en él son realmente
encuentra sosiego fortaleza y sobre todo
consuelo
el hijo de nelson mandela muere estando
en el show encarcelado encarcelado y no
se le permite ir al funeral y en lejos
de retraerse y deprimirse lo que hace es
intensificar el volumen de cartas que
mandaba a su familia sobre todo a sus
hijas ya su esposa en ellas les demostró
el profundo amor que sentía y el
agradecimiento de aún tener las vías
nelson mandela por supuesto es uno de
los líderes más influyentes y cuando
salió de la cárcel alzo uno de sus puños
en señal de desafío porque sabía que
tenía todavía mucho que demostrar pero
cinco años más tarde levanta sus dos
puños porque sabe que se ha convertido
con las elecciones con el gana de las
elecciones en el líder político de todas
las razas
decimos que tanta paciencia y tanta
constancia en el show
lo han vuelto all volvieron el líder más
inspirador de todos los tiempos pero
sobre todo el que tiene una visión más a
largo plazo de hecho dijo hoy es hoy el
pasado es pasado y nos toca mirar hacia
el futuro hoy como no pensar en nelson
mandela y en esa inmensa paciencia que
desarrolló cuando nosotros hoy en día y
nuestras acciones de hoy en esta época
de crisis son las que van a enmarcar el
futuro y a las las que van a construir
un futuro mejor en épocas de
racionalización de los bienes materiales
lo más importante es construir y
desarrollar bienes espirituales es por
eso que hoy los dejó con la palabra
presidio que en latín significa volver
de un salto y que repasa los siete
rasgos fundamentales que vimos a través
de estas tres historias desde la
determinación de una gorda hasta el
humor de los ex prisioneros de guerra
muchas gracias
[Música]